hospitalisé pour une thrombose en
février cynthia est revenu plus
rapidement à domicile grâce à
l'accompagnement en fer ayant fait une
demande pour que j'aide la
physiothérapie avec le CSC à la maison
et on a installé chez elle de
l'équipement normalement réservé aux
hôpitaux on m'a fourni un lit d'hôpital
pour que je puisse revenir à la maison
une approche que Québec voudrait pousser
plus loin ce sont des patients qui sont
admis mais ils ne sont pas admis à
l'hôpital ils sont ennemis à leur
domicile c'est ce qu'on appelle
maintenant l'hospitalisation à domicile
avec des services mais aussi de
l'équipement par exemple des bons bandes
d’oxygène on peut traiter à la maison
une série de maladies assez sérieuse par
exemple une insuffisance cardiaque une
insuffisance rénale un diabète qui ont
besoin d'ajustements de médicaments 40
millions sont tirés de la rémunération
des médecins spécialistes pour lancer
huit projets pilotes en Montérégie à
Montréal Laval dans les Laurentides
Lanaudière et à Québec cette alternative
à l'hospitalisation permettra de libérer
des lits d'hôpitaux un objectif qui
suscite quelques craintes il faudrait
pas que leur première idée ou le critère
numéro 1 soit de libérer le lit parce
que ça convient pas à tout le monde
l'hospitalisation à domicile se fait en
partie grâce à des outils de
surveillance à distance qui sont en
développement reste qu'il faut tout de
même de la main d'oeuvre